Now that the car is mostly done, all
that's left are some finishing touches.
So follow along as we clean up the code,
put a proper mesh on the car, make some
improvements, and add a few extra
things.
Now that we understand how the physics
work, we can take all the code from the
car script and put it inside the wheels
in a more compact form.
So after rearranging the code, here's
what we got. The wheels properties are
now neatly divided into groups and
categories. And you can collapse the
wheel properties group to see how the
values that affects how they behave. On
the motor category section, we have a
new is steer variable that the car can
use to know whether the tire can turn or
not. And I've put a toggle to show or
hide the debug force arrows. On the
ready function, we now set the target
position of the raycast to make sure it
starts correctly. And all the physics
calculations are now inside the apply
wheel physics that receives a raycast
car as a parameter. Inside here, we have
all the previous physics functions
combined. Before subate ray cast, rotate
the wheels and calculate the tire forces
on the spring calculation. One notable
change here is that now we set the
contact variable value before we
calculate the tire velocity. This way we
have a proper velocity based on the
center of the wheel. Then we calculate
the acceleration, the traction x forces
and the traction z forces. I have
removed the skit marks code from here.
We are having the car script control if
it want the skit marks or not. Also the
gravity.y y value is now retrieved with
minuscar getg gravity.y instead of the
project settings value. This will give
us the gravity value after the rigid
body gravity scale is applied. And
finally at the end we apply all the
forces. But you can also just call apply
force once with the sum of the x y and z
forces. Now let's take a look at how the
car changed. First we added a class name
raycast car. So we have the autocomplete
working correctly on the wheels. I also
added the show debug option here and an
on ready var total wheels to cach how
many wheels we have. This is used by the
wheel script to correctly calculate the
traction forces on the steering rotation
function. We now check if the wheel has
the is steer property instead of hard
coding which wheel to rotate and it is
now called by passing a wheel as a
parameter. Finally, the physics process
now calls the wheels apply wheel physics
passing itself as a reference to the
function. Then we call the steering
rotation to rotate the wheel and place
and activate our skid marks. I just had
to expose the wheels grip factor so we
can check when to do it. And that's it
for the refactor. All things should
still work the same.
So let's enable the debug arrows on our
wheels by checking the show debug option
and see how our car is doing. Now let's
finally put a mesh into our car to see
how it is done. I have model in Blender
using some references and we are going
to use that. I exported it into two
models, one for the car body and one for
the wheels. So, first let's drag the car
body inside the car node.
Position it at about the same location
of our box mesh
and rotate it to the correct
orientation.
Now, let's drag the wheels inside each
of the raycasts.
Hide the prototype meshes
and try to position them at the right
spot. You can use the side view to help
you with that.
And that sounds about right. Always make
sure you are moving the raycast itself
and not the wheel mesh. Now I'll select
all the raycasts and put them into the
same Y position.
And also adjust the front wheels just a
bit back.
Select all the reccasts again and let's
change the rest distance to 0.1. This is
how far the spring is going to extend
from the current position. The wheel
position right now is when it is at its
most compressed state and we will give
it an over extend of 0.05 just to make
it a bit harder to flip at high speeds.
The wheel radius for this should be
about 0.33 m. Our other values are fine
as they are. Now let's fix the X
position and tuck in the wheels back
into the car.
So we'll adjust a single wheel here at
about minus0.8 in the X and invert this
value for the wheel on the other side.
Do the same for the back wheel and make
extra sure you're moving the ray cast
and not the wheel mesh like I did here
at first. It's really easy to move the
wrong one at this stage. So let's set
the X to minus 0.8 and the opposite side
to 0.8.
I also mistakenly moved the wheel mesh
here at some point. So let's make sure
the wheel mesh is at 00 0 again. Now if
your wheels are slightly off position
like this, it is probably because the
wheel mesh origin is not exactly
centered and they are not mirrored like
this wheel I made. So I need to rotate
the mesh 180° to make sure its correct
face is pointing outwards.
And I ended up changing the wheels X
position to minus 0.85 and 0.85 on the
other side. And finally, don't forget to
delete the old meshes because our wheel
script will assume the first object is
the mesh that it needs to move. So,
select all the old meshes and delete
them. Now, we finally have something
that looks like a real car we can play
around with. But another thing we can do
is improve our collisions.
We are still using the old box shape
collision. So, select the car model node
and enable editable children to see
what's inside. Select the actual mesh
node and inside the mesh menu, click on
create collision shape. Here, let's set
the collision shape type to single
convex and create it. This creates a
collision node with the shape of our
car. So, let's drag it to the car rig
body and delete our old box shape. I
also like to push the shape just a bit
up so we have some leeway for it not to
scrape the bottom. But you can fine-tune
this in any way you want. And
everything's still working with much
better collisions now. So, now that we
can collide, let's put some obstacles. I
have here a couple of traffic objects
that I can quickly drag into the game.
They are just simple rigid bodies that
have a couple of simple collision
shapes. Just make sure you change the
body's mass to reflect what they are.
There are two different ways you can
create those objects. Go to the modeling
part settings and set the root type to
rigid body 3D. And then we manually add
our collision shapes or leave it as it
is. But select the mesh, enable physics
and set the body type to dynamic. This
will turn the mesh node into a rigid
body and create its own shape
automatically.
After that, right click the model and
choose new inherited scene. This will
save a scene based on the imported model
where you can make changes and add new
things to it. And now we have some
obstacles to play around with. Now,
let's go see and mitigate one of the
biggest limitations of Raycast cars,
sharp bumps and small gaps. To
demonstrate that, let's create a very
thin CSG shape. Make sure to enable
collision and duplicate it to create a
small gap. If we try to run over this,
something really strange happens. Our
wheels jump very high and they overlap a
lot. Let's take a closer look. The
raycast is a singular rayon, so it can't
actually detect if the wheel is inside
an object. And if it is an obstacle like
this cube, the ray will suddenly change
the spring position.
This makes the wheel looks like it have
teleported and will make the spring
force suddenly really high. The wheels
will also fall if there is any small
enough gap where the brake can hit its
bottom. So let's see what we can do to
solve some of these issues. Let's open
our wheel script to avoid the wheel from
teleporting. We can lurp the wheels into
position and smoothly move them. So you
will use the move toward function and
move it from the current position to
minus spring length at a rate of 5 *
delta for now. And because we are
setting the contact variable to be the
wheel position, this will also make the
spring forces slightly less drastic.
And since we are already here, let's
talk about another problem. The
resulting spring length value here can
be negative when hitting the ground too
fast. What this does is put the wheel
mesh beyond its most compressed state
and this can push the wheel up far
enough to make it go outside of the car.
To fix this, we just need to make sure
the value is higher than zero by using
max f. Now the car will behave slightly
better. But to completely solve this
issue, we would need to implement a
multra cast wheel or a shape cast wheel.
A multi-raycast wheels uses multiple ray
cast to prevent these types of errors.
And while they are still very
performant, the code becomes more
complex. The shape cast solution would
also change the script a bit, but more
importantly, it is much more performance
intensive than a few ray casts. We can
change our car to use shape cast in the
future, but let's keep it using raycast
for now. Now that our car is mostly
done, let's make a proper camera to
follow it around. And there is a very
easy to implement follow camera we can
use. So let's create a camera 3D as a
child of the car. Put it at the back
and make sure you enable current if you
have multiple cameras in your scene. If
we start our game now, the camera works,
but it looks very stiff and not good at
all. We can try other positions, but it
feels really bad having the camera
bobbing around along with the car. So,
let's create a new camera script that
will control the camera and call it car
follow camera. Here we are going to have
a mean distance variable of four, a max
distance variable of eight, the camera
height of three and an unready var
target that gets the parent of the
camera, the car.
On the physics process, we declare a
distance variable from target that is
the global distance of the camera minus
the target global position. Next, you'll
check if the distance is within the min
and max distances and clamp it by using
the from target.normalized normalized
and multiplying it by the min or max
distances.
We'll then set the targety to be our
height and set its position to be the
target's position plus our distance
variable from target. Now all that's
left is to rotate the camera towards the
target. But we need to make sure our
look direction is not collinear with the
direction we chose. So first let's
create a variable called look direction.
And the trick you can do here is to take
the absolute value of the direction and
reduce it by the vector up. If the
variable is not zero, that means our
rotation axis is not colinear with the
vector 3 up and we can safely rotate it
without warnings. Our final step is to
make sure the camera has the top level
option enabled. This means its position
will not update with its parent node and
it is completely independent. And just
like that, we have a very nice looking
camera. And it even turns by itself when
steering.
Now, to make it just a little bit
better, we can make it so it can rotate
with the mouse, too. To do that, we will
reparent our camera to a new node 3D and
call it camera pivo. This is not going
to be a top level node, and we'll follow
the car's position. Inside the camera
script, our target now is two parents
nodes above. So we add another get
parent call
and we'll create a new input function to
check for the mouse movement. If the
event is input event mouse motion, the
mouse has moved. So now we will set the
camera stop level to false which will
make the camera follow the pivot nodes
position. Then we will rotate the pivo
with get parent rotate by the minus
event.x
how much the mouse has moved since and
multiply this by a small value. As the
rotation use radians, you multiply it by
0.001.
And after our camera has rotated, we
reenable the top level back again. In
fact, let's create a camera sensibility
variable for the camera's mouse move
speed and use that instead.
Now, we can move the camera with the
mouse,
but also have it rotate by itself with
the car.
It is not perfect, but it works quite
fine for such a small bit of code.
Now let's change some other things and
improve our brakes. Remember that KTO
has a default linear damp setting that
it stops all movements. We do not want
that to affect our car. So let's select
the rigid body. And inside linear, we
can change the dent mode from combine to
replace. This will replace the default
linear damp with the value here zero and
make it stop affecting our car. And
because we don't have this stopping
force anymore, we can turn back our
acceleration back to 600. Now all that's
stopping the car is the Z traction
forces of the wheels which by the way
should have a grip force curve just like
the side forces to make them stop the
car more realistically. And speaking of
curves, let's improve our tire curves
and save them as godo resources. So
let's select the front wheel, click on
the grip curve arrow, and select save
as. We'll name this car tire front. Now
select one of the back wheels and save
it as car tire back. Then select the
other front wheel and use the quick load
to select the front wheel we just
created. And do the same for the other
back wheel, loading the back wheel curve
instead. Now if you make the back tires
has less adherence. This makes the car
more prone to naturally drifting. So
let's decrease this grip curve just a
bit. And you can see the other back tire
curve also changed while our front tires
continue to be the same because we use
different curves for them. You can also
double click the resource directly and
change the curve from there.
But now the car can start drifting when
turning at high speeds without us having
to press the hand brake key. Let's just
increase this curve a bit to make it
harder to lose control.
And now the car behaves much more
naturally.
And we can still use our drift button as
usual. But one thing our car is still
missing is a real brake button. So add a
new brake button.
And let's open our wheel script.
We are going to stop the car by changing
the Z direction traction when the button
is pressed. So let's add a new export
variable called Z brake traction of 0 25
and a is breaking variable to check if
it needs to break.
Now in our Zraction code we just need to
check if is braking is true and if it is
we override the Z friction to be our new
Z brake traction. Now we just need to
make sure our car sets the braking.
Instead of using the input function, we
are going to use input is action pressed
brake and set the wheel is braking.
Now we can press the brake key and make
our car stop. And finally, just for fun,
let's see how we can make our carry
things. So let's make it tow another
car.
Duplicate our original car.
Move it back. And let's also rotate it
just so it looks different. Now let's
delete some stuff we don't need on the
second car. Delete the camera.
Select the front wheels and disable
steer so it doesn't rotate. And on the
back wheels, disable motor so it doesn't
accelerate the car. Now Godo makes it
really easy to pull things with joints.
So that's what we are going to use. Add
a new pin joint 3D. This node will
attach two rigid bodies together and
it's really easy to use. First let's
position the pin joint at the position
between the cars. This will be the point
that binds the objects together.
So, put the car one on node A and car
two on node B. And we can now tow away
the other car. The car gets lower
because it is pushing more mass. It now
has to overcome the tire friction of the
car at the back. But they don't collide
with each other. To make sure they do,
disable the exclude nodes option.
And now the cards will collide with each
other while it's being pushed.
Another option is to use the more
complicated 6D doof joint.
This lets you set angle limits for each
rotation axis. So we can set exactly how
much it can turn on each axis, locking
it at certain angles. And because we can
use this to limit the placement, we can
enable the exclude nodes back again. We
can also make our car smaller and reduce
its mass just for fun.
But the biggest problem with the 6DF is
that they can become really unstable
when you hit their limit angles at high
speeds. So you might have to adjust
their options here and play around with
these values or even change the joint
position a bit to prevent this. But they
can be a bit finicky to work with. The
basic pin joint is much less
problematic. And just to finish things
up, when the car lands too fast, it
might scrape the ground and stop the
movement in a weird way. To prevent
this, you can create a new physics
material for the car's rigid body and
set the friction to zero or a lower
value. Now your car will hit the ground
and continue forward with no problem.
But that's it. The basics are now done.
There is still a lot more we can do to
improve and much more complicated ways
we can use to make our car simulation
more advanced. The basics are meant to
be a simple implementation that loosely
simulates a car. So there are a lot that
was left out, but that's the end of the
series for now. I might come back to it
later and add a few things to slowly
make it into a game or make another car
focusing on more realistic simulations.
But in case you want to continue this on
your own, here's a to-do list of things
you can research. You can replace our
simple wheel rotation by the Acurman
steering that will make each wheel
rotate different amounts depending on
the location of the wheel. This is a
real technique that is used on cars to
make the tires lip less on turns. And
there is also the anti-acrian that is
used on cars such as Formula 1 ones that
makes it better at high speed turning.
You can also simulate the wheel RPM,
torque, and transmission to calculate
realistic acceleration forces. And
realistic lateral forces can be
calculated by using the Pashika magic
formula, which is a very complicated
derived formula that calculates forces
based on several factors. There's a very
nice explanation of the values here, and
you can use the reduced simple formula
at the end that works quite well for
simulated games and much more. But
that's really it for now. As always, the
files used here are available on Patreon
if you want to support me. I hope you
can make some great games and until next
time.